hi and welcome to my video series of
biotechnics explained in five minutes
where i explain a concept of biology in
less than
five minutes or so in today's
installment we'll talk about hydrophobic
interaction chromatography
which is a chromatographic technique in
which hydrophobic
interaction is used as a principle for
separation
now this chromatographic technique is
way better than other kind of
chromatographic technique
because the way the proteins are eluted
or purified
is less denaturating and the proteins
could be
recovered in a native state or in a less
denaturated state before we start the
video
please hit that subscribe button and
don't forget to press the bell icon to
get notification
and do share my channel in social media
such that i can reach
bigger audience if you want to support
me please go to my patreon page
and my courses are also available in
unacademy
so use 10 percent ap 10 for a 10
discount back to the workflow
of hydrophobic interaction
chromatography
just like any other column
chromatographic method the workflow is
very same
it starts with equilibration then
binding wash
and followed by the illusion step but
the difference
lies in terms of the column material so
the hydrophobic interaction
chromatography column is packed with a
hydrophobic bead
a general bead whose surface is coated
with a hydrophobic material
so we'll talk about the column material
later but
these hydrophobic coating can actually
interact with the hydrophobic surface
of the protein and this is
the basis of binding like this is how
the protein binds to the column
now let us imagine a hypothetical
situation where there are two proteins
one protein has higher hydrophobic
surface
generally the protein a and the protein
b
has lower degree of hydrophobic surface
we can understand
that there would be greater extent of
hydrophobic interaction
between protein a and the column
compared to protein b
so in layman's term protein a would bind
strongly to the
column compared to protein b now
whenever
hydrophobic interaction chromatography
is practiced
the column is loaded with a high salt
buffer
and the high salt buffer is key to
understand
the principle of hydrophobic interaction
chromatography
in a moment we would try to understand
that
so we have already understood that
hydrophilic regions and hydrophobic
regions could be present on the surface
of protein there could be patch of both
now
under solvated condition when the
protein is dissolved in a buffer
there would be a lot of buffer molecules
or
lot of solvent molecules generally water
coating the entire surface of the
protein
this would mask all the hydrophobic
patches
on the protein right and in this
situation there would be
no interaction between the hydrophobic
patch
and the hydrophobic surface of the
column because everything is
masked by the solvent molecules
some agent is required to get rid of
these kind of
coating effect and those reagents are
nothing but
cosmotropic salt such as ammonium
sulphate
in this situation the solvent molecules
would make themselves themselves more
busy to dissolve
the salt ions or they would interact
more with the salt ions
compared to the protein as a result the
protein surface
would be now free and exposed when the
proteins
hydrophobic surface is exposed it is
free
to interact with the hydrophobic
material of the hydrophobic interaction
column and in this way it can
bind to the column now we have to
understand
the extent of binding and the salt
concentration
that is why two hypothetical situations
are presented here
in situation b a protein let's say
protein b
interacts with the hydrophobic column
which has a lot of hydrophobic surface
first of all this interaction is very
strong
right compared to another interaction
where
protein a binds to the column and
protein a has very tiny bit of
hydrophobic surface so protein b
is binding way stronger than protein a
as depicted in this situation
now you can see a very little amount of
salt
is required to get rid of protein b
and the beads interaction in the
background you can see
a very less amount of salt molecules are
depicted
this is because these salt molecules
actually increase the entropy and allow
this interaction to happen
make this interaction thermodynamically
favorable
when the salt ions would decrease the
water molecule would resolvate these
protein and prevent the interaction
right but as the interaction is stronger
between
these protein and the bead very low
amount of salt is required in other
words
high level of solvent is required
to elute or to get rid of the
interaction between
protein b and the bead whereas even
high level of solid concentration can
get rid of protein a
from the bin right so always remember
higher the salt concentration greater is
the chance of hydrophobic interaction
right because higher the salt
concentration
there would be way more exposed surface
let us imagine the illusion profile the
illusion is
done in a stepwise decreasing salt
gradient
that means you start with a higher salt
concentration and end up
with a low salt concentration at very
high salt concentration the proteins
which have very low
level of hydrophobic surface exposed
would be eluted
because obviously the interaction is
weak whereas at very low salt
concentration
proteins which have quite a lot of
exposed surface would be
exposed so we can would be eluted
now we can understand the sequence of
illusion and the principles behind that
in general higher the hydrophobicity
stronger
the interaction and higher the
hydrophobicity
lower the salt it takes to elute because
the salt
would promote or induce binding by
exposing the surface
so overall what we learned from this
video
is the more hydrophobic the molecule
less salt
is required to promote the binding
because the hydrophobic surface has a
strong effigy towards a
towards these hydrophobic patches on the
protein whereas
more salt is required for a protein
which has very low extent of hydrophobic
surface
now this is
depiction of the hydrophobic material
used in hic chromatography
both has tertiary butyl or
methyl groups which are highly
hydrophobic in nature
other than these factors hydrophobic
interaction chromatography
based on is based on ph changes
temperature changes and types of salt
that is used for illusion
generally higher temperature is
favored for hic whereas
cosmotropic salts are good for
hydrophobic
interaction chromatography in contrast
the chaotropic salts
is not good for hydrophobic interaction
chromatography technique
so in this video we reviewed the concept
behind hydrophobic interaction
chromatography
in details by the way guys these
hydrophobic interaction chromatography
columns could be used in hplc settings
for better and faster purification of
our desired protein
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up and don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you guys